The joe rogan experience.
Yeah,
let's talk about that one because what we got,
we had video of that one too.
You went undercover with the Antifa and uh,
that fucking,
that one was disturbing to me because,
uh,
first of all you look like slide right in like a glove buddy.
Like I was almost matching the guy when I got there.
Guy,
Gal,
we don't know.
Um,
and I thought our costume wardrobe lady had actually just,
just stolen his clothes because it was almost identical to what he was wearing.
Isn't it though that when you were a slender man,
like people assume many things.
Oh yeah.
I can get away with so much crap.
That weird.
Yeah.
Well like what is it about slender people?
There's something there,
right?
Like what is it about slender people that are almost always left wing weakness?
Whoa.
You think so?
Sorry.
It could be the same reason they see the American flag is right wing.
They see this,
this,
you must be the Third Reich.
Did I say third wreck?
I don't even know what it is.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
I Dunno.
I don't know what happened.
Designs,
check them out on that is really,
it's actually really nice and that turnaround is that steel?
Yeah,
that's pretty cool.
Guy makes them.
That's it.
I can usually,
I can usually tell when someone's approaching us,
if they're friendly or fell by their posture and their body size,
the guy walks in,
your body says,
I'm like,
oh,
that's probably a friendly guy like
queer looking at hundred and 40 pound man like myself.
Approaches and like,
ah,
we got to get out of dodge.
He has a shank or screwdriver because I had done you pass it out.
I did so many shotguns an hour ago.
I know it.
I know I didn't go because I was like,
I had done two and now I get made every time I go out after you know,
you dressed as a trainee and you need to be Wendy Davis.
My wig flies off.
She still goes along with it.
I'm on every night.
You got to go in there on a technical level.
Also didn't want to pull it.
The seal team six mission between Wednesday and Friday shelf.
So it's true,
but what happened is then when you were in,
you wanted to go back.
That's true.
I was juiced.
How did it get site explained to me how it got set up,
how you did it.
Like what?
What,
what was the meeting balls of stuck boss.
Well,
I mean these kind of,
these things are much different than the Burlington Vermont kind of gigs.
I mean that was a throwaway.
This one took months of planning as RegEd to especially to a,
to infiltrating the backend of Antifa red and red.
We call him Richard.
We have a guy who does research for us.
Ah,
don't make it,
I won't get into anything specific,
but he is only the high level professor.
Okay.
He has a,
he has a 650 pound squat.
She's like Bain and real life and a brilliant,
he was the one who found the salon pedophile.
That's why we broke that.
She was the,
to file the article where the guy who was currently actively a pedophile,
he sent it to me within 10 minutes.
But he's the man of the chairman today,
currently out of wasn't a practicing pedophile.
Right.
You know who he was.
He was,
he talked about grooming and all that stuff when we wrote about it.
Yeah.
Really double down on it too,
didn't it?
Didn't it again,
three more articles.
Yeah.
Anyway,
the point is registers,
registers,
just brilliant.
Remove those articles.
I don't know,
maybe they did,
but they did like two or three.
But red is a brilliant researcher.
And so at this point,
explain that though.
Cause you were glossing over this for people that are just listening.
Please explain like what that was like those articles.
Uh,
sorry.
Yeah,
we're starting off with that.
So a salon.com what was their first articles?
I'm a pedophile.
That an,
I'm not a monster.
And it was talking about how you know,
the way to deal with us as again,
not to stigmatize us.
I'm like,
listen,
I'm sorry.
At a certain point I'm empathetic,
but we send you to therapy.
You still want to have sex with kids.
We take you out to a village,
we shoot you.
We can't take that risk.
Sorry.
That's it.
Um,
so he was like,
I'm not a monster.
And talked about how his struggles with his family.
Okay.
You can kind of understand it.
But then Reggie did some research.
We found all of his online message board is,
is pseudonyms,
has usernames and coded language about grooming.
Uh,
drew me mean like your grooming kids online.
So we found all of it and we released an article on it and then salon release
another article where he responded and didn't call us up by name of,
it was like my week in the right wing hates fear and they ran it on salon.
Like we're the bad guys because we found out that you're grooming children and
they released a few and we're like,
we just realized,
okay,
this is the thing,
kind of like hormone blockers for kids' salons.
Cool.
With an active pedophile.
Let's move on now.
We're not going to do it.
There's no more convincing to be done here.
So red was the one who found that in red lodge was the one who infiltrated a lot
of the antifa groups.
You know,
that,
that's not his real name.
But he has so many,
this guy's just brilliant.
So He'd been doing research on the backend,
uh,
upon request and was so good.
So we had all this research.
We knew who these people were.
We kind of knew what they were planning with Ben Shapiro going into Utah.
Um,
as a matter of fact,
we were going to go to Berkeley right before that.
But then last minute we found out that they weren't going to do it because we
know where they meet.
We were on their cryptic apps where they would text you.
So as these apps that you would download,
like I don't know if we're like,
are we allowed to say that?
I don't know.
Yeah.
The FBI came to us for information afterwards.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
we're tracking.
There were arrests made,
uh,
because of your undercover thing.
Well,
arrest made on the people who we see on the cover.
So they committed crimes again later that day and were arrested.
So the same person who handed him a shank later that day assaulted.
So that was the rest of,
so,
so Raj gets you the information and then you,
how do you make contact with these people?
We will,
we were part of their Facebook grouping so we found out where they wanted to
meet,
when um,
what and where.
And we show up the campus and I walk in as Jason Antifa person new to the
organization.
Say I want to be involved blue contacts and a beanie.
That's all it takes.
It's much shacks on the tech side.
Blue Contacts.
Just because we're on a budget we need to disguise.
But why,
why do you need this disguise?
He didn't think you could slip,
you thought it'd be,
would recognize we thought we could have been on the radar even though they
tried to find this in a,
in a,
in Austin and to put it on posters,
we take the interview with Tim Kennedy and they were passing,
passing out flyers just when you got waterboarded.
No,
no.
That was another time.
And I would much rather than whining.
Yeah,
he did.
He did.
That was no joke.
And I'd rather do that than the CNN 16 hour live stream.
That's not a joke.
I'd rather be waterboarded but anyways,
good enough.
Dot.
Yeah.
So we show up at this coffee house there me,
Starbucks on campus
where he meets at Starbucks.
So I found him met up.
Uh,
he gives me the cryptic messaging APP.
was it a he or she did you find out?
We don't know.
I was sure it was a heat because it was a wedding band and the chairs,
Europe Zur Zur sitting there with his wedding band,
uh,
iPhone seven and is,
is brought on the side.
It gives me the APP and says we'll see you tomorrow.
So I say,
okay,
see you.
Then he gives me full communication.
They did roll call,
the roll call and it,
and it's okay.
Everyone roll call.
We've got Jason and the group like,
yeah,
it's like Firebird,
Firebird.
Uh,
well they went down to like all these like Firebird and rogue two in row flame
thrower nine.
And then there was,
we'll,
we'll will that that was as well named feral fan we found immediately cause I
used to swim so swiftly.
Well it's so easy to find.
How can you figure out who will was?
Well,
because the phone numbers are also listed.
It's encrypted messaging APP doesn't lie,
take screenshots,
but it turns out if you have another film,
you could take a photo of your screen.
She was a physical camera.
They didn't seem to work out this kink in the plans.
The snapchat thing when people are sending Dick pics like yeah,
normal,
go see it.
No one's going to say,
well you can't say,
you can't just reach us.
It just informs the person,
which is so much worse than no,
someone actually took it.
It's like yeah,
that just makes it worse for everybody to take note of it with another camera.
Like you said.
I'm sorry.
So go ahead.
All these people roleplaying,
they're there in dungeons and dragons.
Exactly.
So we uh,
we go back to her hotel,
get ready for the next day,
uh,
and show up on campus where they're supposed to,
to,
to meet up and get together nervous as hell because he's like,
when should we play?
So it was more nervous the day before cause they shouldn't know what I was
walking.
Do you want them to stop?
We want to play it first up.
They are all like three seconds as much from from Antifa four.
Which one do you want me to start with?
The how?
Find One.
So roll the dice producer.
So,
um,
these people different than me.
They were openly advocating violence and they were openly,
they were offering to give you a gun?
Not at first.
No,
not at first.
Look,
that's why I say I want to do,
because you actually said the funny part before you said we got into a fight and
you said this is not my job description.
And I said,
it is exactly in your job description.
You have to go do this right now.
And,
uh,
we,
we had security everything.
But I remember you were really,
and then after the clips you'll see after they gave you the knife and we were
finally on reports with the cops at that point he goes,
oh,
I'm going to go back in.
I think I can really mess with him.
Like,
no you can't.
They just handed you a prison shank and told me they had a sawed off shotgun.
You can't go back in there.
So once he was in it,
I had to reign him back.
There's like a little little too pop pop a couple of times.
Crazy.
He's got a little crazy.
Okay,
so let's play this.
This is my meeting at that Starbucks pluck product placement days.
A Guy,
this is a guy I think I play it.
Oh,
this is telling you how to show up.
It's hard.
Tactics
cannot prepare for what we're planning to have a toolbox full of shit.
Did you bring your gun on the border between just regular right on the border is
going regular rifle.
It us all up and dial in a sawed off style shot.
That's a girl.
Yeah.
I thought so when I showed up to this one.
But you know
Jamie is one where the hand handed Jared was an ice pick,
he said or what was it?
It was a nice pic.
It was a sharp pointy end,
but it was like a school that screwdriver handle a case coming.
Okay,
so here it is.
I think they were lying.
No,
but this is
and telling me how like I can procure my own a bars.
There we go.
Thanks.
Played five inches.
You strap it on your leg and the Kebar sponsor of Antifa now,
by the way,
really stamp on my shit is
okay.
So what they're doing is first of all,
that person never stabbed anybody in their fucking life.
Right?
So these are dorks and what they're doing is they're deciding now they're going
to take action and they're going to enlist the aid of a bunch of other people.
Did you think at that point in time,
like maybe these people are looking for suckers that are willing to do fucked up
shit for them?
She ain't stabbing anybody?
I absolutely think so.
When I showed up,
I met,
there was like four of them when I got there,
they were all running late,
the socialists were all running late,
late
and one of them actually said,
sweetheart,
there are honeybee.
I was like,
yeah,
that's the beauty of being unemployed.
I can just show up on time anywhere I want.
I'm like there is a silver lining I guess,
but just eating.
She was still late.
Oh she was?
Yeah.
She's like so she,
okay so I get there first I'm thinking,
okay this is a bus.
This is a really sad group of people.
Right.
Cause I don't know about the weapons at this point.
I just the,
okay there's,
I'm,
I'm expecting like forties guys in the,
what they called black bloc,
all black goggles,
everything.
And it just looks like a really sad social club.
So like get there,
sit down for a bit and like three minutes in you start telling me they start
passing me stuff,
telling me everything you just saw and I'm thinking,
oh my lord,
this is not,
I,
I need to get out.
I need to get out to me while I'm on the other side of this.
Cool.
Cause Ben Shapiro was being some of the other side of the school and you know
Ben Shapiro's there.
So there are a lot of fans.
I'm kind of taking pictures and you know I got got spotted some take care of my
phone.
If I went home,
I said let me just shut off my phone taking pictures and let me just,
and I see it in chair.
It's like they're handing me knives.
What do I do?
Like quick it.
I'm like,
okay,
I need,
I need to,
I need to fast.
And you think quick.
Yeah.
So I told him I had to take a dump and I just left.
That was hilarious.
What the crazy thing about that is that you bring us the footage.
So there are cops right there.
So we tell the cops,
because I'm like,
we've got to get him through this,
whatever it is,
quad or whatever is there
here I think,
oh yeah,
that's it.
That's not playing.
Let's get corrupted file here.
Go.
Rather than circle.
And they were handing out sharp objects to stab people with said they had
someone come in with this guy works for local lines too.
Late night hosts comedians to find this out.
You know what?
I wish you guys luck.
Yes.
You just saw correctly even being shown the footage in the presence of police
officers to confirm authenticity.
They walked away.
Also,
I should note here is from Nightline who was on my podcast airs.
He knew about the footage and the whole story too.
I don't like offered it to them and ask,
give us a brief spot and when they actually put together weeks later after if
did come out so he had to acknowledge it,
but he put together a small little brief montage of our video that took place on
items.
Little profile,
peaceful event though.
It was not without some controversy.
What happens is to me what's so crazy,
it's like again,
I offered it to the local guy.
People who do news,
you know April O'neil,
they're not,
they want the exclusive.
I said,
hey man,
do you want this?
Like to run this?
Cause he worked for ABC or local Fox or something and he's doing an Instagram
videos with five,
you know,
following and sees,
oh,
a heart go up on his screen.
So I'm looking at him like,
I'm like,
listen man,
do you want this?
And he goes,
uh,
what does it,
so hold on,
this is that we tell them exactly what we had and we show them the cryptic APP.
And I'm like,
hold on a second.
We're not here or the police.
So we're showing it to him and he walks away.
He's like,
well,
I've got gotta do my job.
I'm like,
this isn't a part of your job.
This isn't,
he didn't think it was.
And that to me was in saint,
we weren't looking for it necessarily a school.
We just kind of get this as wide as possible.
He had a rhyme going down the street with their protests.
He had a good day.
Yeah,
that's what he did.
He was doing interim and you'll see people peacefully protesting.
And I'm like,
hold up his Instagram,
hey,
hello Donald Trump's luck to him.
And he just didn't have authority that he was trying to have,
didn't fit the narrative.
Same thing with a guy from Nightline.
It didn't fit.
So the narrative was the anti Trump protesters,
which is what people were tuning into the news for.
It wasn't peaceful,
peaceful.
There were snipers on the roof tops for that little Jube and Shapiro.
This is two weeks after he's a,
he's a smarmy little bastard I love,
but he's like,
I could see how he pisses people off.
But he's brilliant.
He's very,
very smart because my first lawyer,
he negotiated my contract.
He wasn't even entertainment lawyer.
I said,
Ben,
you got a lot of vowels and your last name and I have a contract with money at
play.
Can you help me?
And I think,
I think I can do it.
And that's how I became friends.
I was 18 that's hilarious.
So this is this,
I mean this is the heat of the ANTIFA fight.
Last summer I,
right after Berkeley,
they were really specifically about antifa trying to downplay the violence.
And the,
the undercurrent that I've seen,
they've given that up.
They seem to have accepted the fact that there's a lot of,
some of them,
but I think this ha,
I mean I hate not to toot our own horn,
but I think things like this and that got what 15 lean plays in Facebook and a
few million on,
on a,
on youtube.
And the reason we've got more mileage just because the news refused to cover it
then was it the dean,
someone,
there's some student activities advisor released an official statement saying
nothing happened.
And so we called him.
So that was a fall,
but he remembered listening to that.
We said with the Washington,
what the,
we made up something Washington Harold or something.
She was like,
oh,
it was a really stupid name of Cameron,
one of us.
And we asked who made the statement that this was entirely peaceful because
honeybee,
he said he's speaking on behalf of the police but never actually quoted a name.
So he was,
we figured out real quickly he's speaking on behalf of himself.
And even those opinions we found out he was actually a delegate or something he
was actually officially involved with and stuff at about.
Yeah,
tied to Clinton.
He was a,
he was a kitten staffer.
Yeah.
Supportive and t for this like open supportive and it's very confusing.
It's like,
do you know this?
You got like professors hitting people in the head with bike locks.
Like this is not,
it sounds absurd,
but it's true.
It's not a wise group.
This is not,
this is not a smartly organized refutable of,
you know,
some crazy power structure.
These are,
this is chaos.
Right?
And it's your question earlier.
Yeah,
I do think they were,
I think they prey on losers of society to become part of,
I mean they were so quick to welcome me in because they need the numbers and
they're willing to accept anybody.
There was no filtration system.
I've got to say that if that was a real faction of anti,
that's the saddest fucking faction that it doesn't matter.
We'll Kelly Case and you're,
you're as bad as anybody.
Tell her later that.
So Honeybee got arrested for tasing,
tasing a guy that's in [inaudible] case.
Who did she tase?
No,
the guy sucker punched a different guy.
But something happened.
There was a desktop,
but now are you missed gender and then no god,
I would never do that.
Never.
No.
Honeybee was actually,
they're not my character.
Honeybee was a late socialist.
Got Arrested for Jason to dude.
And then after jail was texting.
You remember that she wanted her knife back.
Oh my God.
Does she know picture?
Cause I texted a picture of me sitting next to,
to Shapiro.
Full getup.
Flipping them the bird.
You texted them a picture in the crypt in encryption APP.
Oh my God,
I should have brought the phone,
actually brought the low back.
I'm gonna go to the cops.
We were like,
you bastard,
give me the knife.
Sat next to Ben in just thumbs up.
Oh my God.
And we told them like when it was going up on youtube,
like keep an eye out tomorrow at six o'clock on Youtube.
So she gets arrested for tasing somebody.
Yeah.
And then what happens now?
No heat for her for all this video of her saying she's got a handgun and we
don't know we,
I mean I think can be saying now we,
I was in a lot of phone calls with,
with the FBI obs on the premise with the FBI and they knew the bike footage was
not terribly surprising to any of them because they were already on their radar.
But they did ask how you got an a cryptic gap.
They did add.
Yeah,
they were,
they were picking my brain for how they function because there they are
organized to a certain extent.
I mean if there is ignore organized as the Berkeley faction or is any other
faction that's,
that's caused trouble,
who knows?
But to some level they are and and that's,
that's where the FBI used us to to kind of help them.
What's,
what we were talking about earlier,
that my,
my take on it is that if you're trying to suppress people that hardcore,
and it's just a guy who's talking and that guy turns out to be Ben Shapiro and
you're calling him a Nazi,
like,
do you see those dangerous in?
Do you see the Yarmulke on his head?
Yeah.
Ben Shapiro's a Nazi,
or you out of your mind like this is you,
you're so far gone that you,
like with every single one of these things,
it diminishes the credibility of this,
this whole movement.
Okay.